Our solution is 6 minus x, divided by the quantity x minus 8. Great job if you
got this rational expression. We factor the numerator the same as before, but
this time in the denominator we want factors of -8 and positive 6. They multiply
to give us -48, and a sum to get us -2. I noticed that x plus 6 and 6 plus x are
really the same factors.So I can cancel those since they equal 1. This leaves me
with the remaining factors, so I have 6 minus x divided by x minus 8. You might
have switched the order of these two terms, giving you negative x plus 6 for the
numerator. This would be okay. You might even have gone a step further, and
factored negative 1 from the numerator, and that would have been okay too. All
of these answers are correct. And if you even followed my advice from the first
time, a negative sign out in front would look like this.